[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
when we talk about whatever we want
girls edition ladies anyway yeah so how
are you ladies I'm good how are you lady
you hope that all of you guys like these
episodes cuz this is a lot of fun just
to get a bunch of females together very
strong independent free thinking females
together that's yes discuss these
articles it's a lot of fun I guess we
should explain why this even happened -
because so or you should explain the
through man explain okay somebody yeah
so I'm just a regular JK Newsday was
supposed to be happening today but Joe
has a karate test test
he's been so excited about it to get a
new belt color ya know cuz he just
started like just kind of started as a
33 year old yeah but so he thinks he's
gonna jump up like a couple levels
possibly but he was just really excited
about it and then I think Bart and David
and some one of their other friends yeah
they were like we should go support him
so like a bunch of the guys wanted to
leave but we still needed to shoot
videos so we decided to put together a
cast that's breathable it's just been so
fun this is ridiculous yeah and there
will be in all guys shoot day spoilers
oh yeah get ready for we tried to stay
away from the dick talk we really did in
the beginning we talked about the
articles were about dicks and periods I
was like okay no period talk no dick
talk and then all articles were like
girl sues guy over big dicks and then
like kids are getting high off periods
we're talking about yeah avoid it so
we're all dict out now though with Jack
you started your channel hopping yeah
yeah I love your videos so far everybody
go check our channel and um so I've only
posted three videos one I just started
talking because I was like I have to
just get this first one but you did that
yeah I just couldn't I was like I can't
think about it is gonna be I have to be
perfect and I'll never do it and then I
just released two other ones but it
still feels really weird like I'm not
used to it at all
but it's fun like I feel like I have
something to look forward to like oh I'm
gonna try to do this like I probably
wouldn't have wanted to stand up and
sing karaoke with you guys but I was
like I have to get footage for the bogs
so it's like somehow it's like forcing
me out of my box
she had a real tight box before you know
it's actually recently but okay yeah
weird one okay it's good I'm proud of
you I start I started my channel four
times now oh no I don't in right now
under construction or is it already
working it's a it's a new camera space I
got a new camera I know you got that
like [ __ ] a month ago no I see what
do you need that for uh it was a camera
that Jo's cannons something my bobber
g7s I don't know the vlog camera yes
okay I think it's a white one I don't
know but then I was like you know I just
need to get it like I need to do this
but then it's so hard it's like [ __ ]
life is not that interesting I wake up I
stream I go back to bed you know so I'm
bailing had to force myself to be
interesting I guess I like the more I
when I started my vlog channel is like I
don't know what's interesting about this
why would anyone watch it and I I don't
know I just made it a point to just flog
about like normal life and what was
interesting to me was that people were
interested in that because it was
different than their life like so
different than their like nine-to-five
job or whatever it is or maybe they live
in a completely different state with
completely different weather and like
just even seeing like California was was
different and I didn't think about it
that way before I was just like okay
well everyone in LA does this language
yeah
go the gym go to audition go you know
home but like yeah I didn't think about
how my life is so much different than uh
then someone watch your vlogs I'm just
like wow I'm learning so much about
alcohol right now cuz I don't drink and
then like I don't get excited because
like I think he made something that you
put in a tray it's put in the fridge for
a little bit I was like I was excited
for some reasons four in the morning is
really weird
yeah after watching your wedding video
and then solving my eyes oh my god I
have you loved me Gina I do I love
wedding videos yeah it is I watched all
of your wedding videos too and I cry
thanks a lot [ __ ]
I know right know yours good thank you
he was so good at words I know words at
work that's why he writes things he
writes me I directed two and Casey
writes also so his his one Casey the way
he edited yours was like um you know it
took him forever too because he really
like put his all in it mm-hmm but she
wasn't at it for [ __ ] no video it was at
the very end I was like I thought I made
it through the whole video without
crying it was [ __ ] no someone else
has to get married so we can all be
there you gotta wake David yeah David
tells me to shut the [ __ ] up but I mean
that well you haven't seen the end of
the video no it's the end of acute so
they're like they're like sick oh my god
tonight reenact occur wholly in the
camera she's holding the camera and
she's like crying and then he goes cuz I
love you more beer this was before after
the ceremony your dad or barf or was it
before before cuz I remember that [ __ ]
and I got into an argument with Joe
about that video
do that cuz like Jo Jo was like at the
wedding right and everyone was crying
like and I was just like why don't you
feel anything and he's just like I don't
know and I just don't feel anything I'm
like you must not feel anything for me
because like everyone was crying like
all the guys are crying except Joe
I can't nothing coming out of his eyes
if you go to a wedding with your
boyfriend you're like you see this yeah
like that's what we're all thinking like
badass and I'm like oh babe they're
brought to throw the flowers I'm gonna
go catch him you want me to catch him
right yeah yeah come back with the
flowers I'm like I got it like that
threatening yeah it's like you're what
you mean like were you looking at Joe
like making his wedding that caused an
argument though no it wasn't an argument
it was just kind of like an exchange
like she wished that is that he felt
like he saw that it was like oh I'm
gonna have that one day with you you
know I get that but she said there was
the arguments I'm like you guys like I
feel like the most the guy's gonna give
you in that situation is like let's say
like the couple says their vows and then
he like grips you look closer I'm like
that's good enough yeah I'm like that
says a lot because something cuz mitt
you know men can't communicate [ __ ]
about their feelings so you know we
gotta translate oh that's like such
that's like the hardest [ __ ] thing
for us right now I'm like just ohon me
what you're viewing so he's really good
at saying what he's feeling it's just
sexually I'm like I want to shoot those
thoughts get dirty
no he grew up very Buddhist so there's
like this like guilt part of it that
he's like working yeah yeah he said his
favorite porn is real estate lady porn
his favorite porn is real estate lady
porn has it got a storyline and he likes
the whole story
those women selling houses you know nice
Killeen business suit
that's hot though I'll wear a suit red
you guys never
okay has no-one ever role-played or been
interested in role-playing I've never
done it I will play do not like
elephants roleplay me in the good net
and the group and the group girl chat I
talked about this oh I've been trying
for a hot minute like I'll be like I was
like yeah I'm your therapist and I'm
going to [ __ ] you but I was like I like
look I pull these guys they want I like
you put in one day you're gonna come
over I'm having Amazon box inside
there's gonna be scrubs a stethoscope
you go lay on this bed
therapist and it'll be I don't know I
was gonna see something creepy but I was
like nevermind I was like I'm gonna be
your daddy but actually I don't want
that I just don't like go out of my way
to get the outfit so the closest I'll do
is like lingerie color leash and like
he's like I won't go all the way just to
call her a leash like a gag flashlight
I'm not gonna buy can't think it's a sri
cuz even just giving a lap dance like I
want to be on sexy [ __ ] and I'm just
like I feel like that comes from
thinking that maybe the person will
judge you if you're not sexy yeah and if
you're like completely compatible with
them and comfortable by using myself
that's why I'm laughing so I'm laughing
at myself for doing it cuz I think if
the guy makes you feel super comfortable
and is like encouraging it and then
playing along to then it like at least
for me I'm just like oh yeah oh yeah and
then like the [ __ ] gets heightened
really fast yeah mm-hmm
once you get caught up in it and you
stop thinking about it you're just like
let's ride it's easier to roleplay no
put that down
we have to wear condoms sometimes that's
what I was talking about and the crew
check that like sometimes because I'm on
birth control and so I used the
fertility episode tells me like oh you
can go without a condom you could take
that raw egg or you can
[Music]
it's like oh no you don't take the rod
dick because you might get pregnant so
those days we have to wear condoms now
but and I've never worn condoms with a
boyfriend so it's like I've only worn it
with people that I wasn't gonna be in a
relationship with it was only one other
person right
totes feels like um you know having a
casual hookup or like yeah having sex
with a stranger or something and so like
we kind of play up on that where it's
like no my husband's gonna be home soon
oh shut up [ __ ] I'll be like I'll be
like you down to role play he's gonna be
like well would you miss intimidated
heat the one thing you're scary switch I
like it yeah I'm very I'm very much a
sweat it could be the little schoolgirl
right if you like and lost it to go and
then you show your ass and then as soon
as he's gonna like get into things like
this goal that's right you're on the
bottom
I will literally either be the
schoolgirl that seduces you or the
schoolgirl that gets the deuce like
whatever you want to do let's go
I'm always submissive oh me too I'm
always like I used to be too I used to
always be submissive to y'all sure was
and then I've been a switch just flipped
but also dude light that [ __ ]
they sure do they like when like you
come in the room you roll up your
sleeves are like alright let's [ __ ]
do this not Steve he's like I will never
be dominant he'll never be oh yeah he'll
never be submissive yeah also I like to
do this thing where because he if he
holds my hands then I literally can't
move and like I'm like trying to get
away he actually can hold me down really
good like he's like you're not going
anywhere and I'm like I feel like at one
point I would be like I always tell them
like you will know when my no actually
means though usually this means yes yeah
it gets scary like they'll be tears like
I think that my Dominus came out when I
like started to use me that I was like I
was like really into like I legitimately
thought that he was like super [ __ ]
sexy I thought he was really masculine
and like my brain just shifted and I was
like I want him that's my man you know
I'll tell him to flip and like I will
completely treat him like he's my
possession and like I'm down for that it
would be a great Dominator
yeah dude dude dude like that [ __ ] to me
my seduction part is like me seducing
him by being submissive ya know yeah
that's fun too though so like I still
get kind of a power with that yeah but
not like a dominant power like I'm
crushing you yeah I've never done that I
haven't been into that just yet it's not
even you know something might switch I
feel like for me it wasn't even a power
thing it was just like you mind
literally a power thing well I'm not
like a it's it's almost like it's almost
like I felt like at one point when I was
with him I felt like this is how dudes
feel about women sometimes when they see
her like yeah this is my girl like this
is my possession I'm like I felt like
this that strongly about a guy making
him sound like a [ __ ] like a little
[ __ ] oh but there's nothing he can do
about it I'm like it's my turn
he was always all dominant too and I was
like that was fun nuh-uh I was just so
here's club ones really what I got once
a guy that I was dating it was very
interesting because I was like super
insolent
what happened she's like visiting you
know once because I was really into like
voyeuristic like I want to be washed and
I want to watch other people but it
wasn't necessarily I want to [ __ ] other
people he was kind of like I don't know
any of y'all you know yeah so we went to
a swingers club and the first one we
went to it was like a it was kind of
lame and the people were older we were
like well what I didn't know was when
you're Asian
you're a [ __ ] unicorn here's club
because there's never any Asians in
there mm-hmm
so it's like it's always like white
people Asian everything stop as soon as
you walk in people look yeah look
yeah like Asian people and black people
are like the unicorns of swingers clubs
yeah so like when I walked in I was like
oh this is interesting and then so we
felt like it was kind of whatever and
then we found like a younger you know
club or whatever and um oh it was the
worst thing ever because like another
asian couple walked in but I I swear to
God like dead asses if this was like my
uncle my auntie they walked in and then
they made eye contact me I was like no
no no no
and then like later on like we saw each
other in like the play rooms and then
they was a play room yeah we've never
been ecology a front room like when you
first walk in it's like a bar it's like
a dance floor like people drink people
just hang out is like it's like a party
like an actual party the playroom in the
back has a guard in the front that makes
sure you don't have your cell phones or
anything with you and there's like in
the back it's like like bedding and like
really pretty like curtains so it looks
like a harem of like just like it's like
it's like the scene in 300 where King
Xerxes has it's like all of the hose
yeah yeah that is real ready yeah
so they have like pillows and there's
like tables with like I'm thinking if
you put a blue light dude oh dude yeah
terrible so I was like there's like a
table full like condoms and wipes and
like like it's very safe particular
whatever and then and they make sure
people don't have phones and [ __ ] to you
on the playroom
I meant auntie and uncle made eye
contact with me
and make him over there like oh god like
and they were like it was like two
Pomeranians they're like 411
oh it's Asian couple you would think
that they you know they sell real estate
but you know and then they're all
progressive of that I was proud of them
but it kind of scared at the same time
but proud you know like Wow and there
were Vietnamese mom house like holy SH
uh did you say no or do they're very
they're all very respectful so they went
up to me they're like accent or no
accent okay you wanna play and I was
like okay and he just walks off I was
just like oh my god I'm proud of you you
know like I'm yeah but I'm so proud of
you yeah it was very weird seeing like
an older Asian couple in there but it's
cool spaghetti parties are dope like did
you guys huh oh yeah we [ __ ] a couple
yeah no a different couple no no other
couple just you and
so you went to a swinger party and
didn't swing well let's uh it's more
like it's for people who want to be like
voyeuristic to be white have sex in
public you can't [ __ ] other people like
I saw different couples like [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't know it was dope it was so
cool live porn yeah I don't think I
could ever get done in a swing or say
but I'm also like very very very
monogamous but I've noticed that a lot
of swingers are older like late 30s
because they're bored yeah I think it's
like a switch gets flipped so like I
don't I don't know what might happen in
like 10 years but for now I'm like no
yeah you got a lot of switches and you
go right one day if I'll whip a little
while ago so who knows but that's why I
like right now I'm like Superman there's
a there's a site have you guys ever done
mojo upgrade before No so mojo upgrade
is a website where you do a test and
it's like a hundred like kinked a
hundred question kink test and you
answer all your stuff and then you
switch and you give your partner the
same quiz and then it shows you only the
things that you guys have in common that
you want to do with each other yeah it's
so good like do it do it behind closed
doors but also you do that [ __ ] for a
video that should we give you still let
me timeout oh yeah yeah it's so like it
like if you say no but your partner says
yes it doesn't show up but if you say
maybe and your partner says yes then
it'll say then it'll show up so you
could put the chair into some weird [ __ ]
and if they're not into it they never
have to know that yes I really want to
take you guys to show you stuff just so
you can see what it's like I want to go
you know it was really like people are
so nice only bid twice usually usually
people say usually people say I've only
done it once no no I only once only
seven time because the first one was
like a smaller like you know you kind of
free to come in and just pay like a
comer price whatever this second one is
they look at your social media profiles
they look and see if you're attractive
or not and this is [ __ ] whatever and if
you qualify
oh yeah we're trying to
if you wanted at your haunting beginning
because you want to get proved yeah wait
a minute this one with the aunties and
uncles I got a pair though this the
smaller the first mine my initial one
was when everyone can kind of go they're
making news on we did one like it's
somewhere in Hollywood or some she'll
know you have to like approve you a lot
of them now you have to get approved
like Steve would never know you didn't
never do that probably do I feel like
these two would like just a look or to
like be like all right let's he's came
for anything thank you yeah this thing
where you kind of want someone watch the
dirty talk though that's not that he
doesn't want to he's just he's just not
familiar with it oh he's only had like
I've been his longest relationship his
longest before me was like three months
oh wow I was gonna say kid he just like
narrate what he's doing but that'd be
weird if forgot was like I'm [ __ ] you
[ __ ] too good that if even like says
something he's about to explode so I can
put all of his concentration right there
so I get it
I didn't get a guy like that once he was
I couldn't can I talk I was just like
good Oh like you ever want someone to
stop respecting you
you know like come on now he's and then
there's like some guys I got so nice
like I don't want to cheat like [ __ ]
stop trying to save me
but the afterwards we like kiss each
other and say we each other and all this
stuff yeah so it's like no yeah I feel
like back in the day I would be like
yeah I want a guy to slap me in the face
but nowaday he come at me I'll be like
not the face you know what use I care
about it yeah yeah we were talking about
monogamous relationships and stuff okay
and people getting bored I was in Vegas
in every time I go to Vegas I always
want to gamble but I was this was like
when I was like 26 25 somewhere around
there yesterday
yeah yes yesterday and my friends were
not they were like they want a party
they want to like go like to a club and
I'm like I'm so not down for that like I
just don't like that but I want to go
gamble and so I was at the craps table
alone in my like Club dress because I
had I'm not down for the tables and the
not down for the clubs and I was
gambling and this couple was right next
to me and they're like oh we're
celebrating our 15th wedding anniversary
oh my god congratulations and then the
guy I ran out of chips and the guy like
put down $250 with the chips in my thing
and he's like he's like keep playing and
like he had a huge stack of chips I'm
like oh this guy just like whatever and
so I started playing and then they kept
being like do you want to keep playing
in our room and I'm like nope those
chips right back no we had been playing
for a while it wasn't like he slid the
chips and then said it was like he's
owed the chips we played for like an
hour
yeah and then he's like hey let's keep
doing this up in our room and I'm like
oh no what did the dealer do was a deer
like old people to see this [ __ ] all the
time they did not blink I'm not so keen
on sharing just yet I'm still not a big
like sharer like threesome issue kind of
person I'm gonna make sure right now I
just like we watched ever do that and
like watching other people I couldn't do
it if I was in a relationship so like
now maybe like a row is single and it
was like oh you know wild Spring Break
you know I don't even know what I would
do with a girl like what no I'm not
thinking about you guys yeah I want to
do that so bad
yeah whoa I got this a lot okay cuz I'm
not gonna ever have it Oh
think about it a lot right watch a
gangbang so my calm and I kind of wish
sucks I never just like one in the front
one in the back it's like oh that
happened for me and like now can I move
now and just move on in life and it's
fine I guess I still got a chance so if
I figure it out the veil yeah might be
overrated who knows
[Music]
[Music]